ricardo 8 et rêche secrétaire général de
la fédération européenne des
journalistes
ces cartes orange bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct ce matin sur la rd
france alors nos collègues ont été
arrêtés dans une zone interdite selon
les autorités polonaises que dit le
droit de la presse dans ce genre de
situation
écoutez on est là face à une situation
de violation évidente des standards
européens en matière de liberté de la
presse on n'hésite pas à la fédération
fvd des journalistes à parler de chance
u11 c'est un acte de censure de la part
du gouvernement polonais
on a enregistré plusieurs incidents dans
la zone des journalistes essaient de
faire leur travail d'informer la
population sur ce qui se passe dans
cette zone frontalière
on a pu assister à des premières
arrestations de journalistes polonais au
tout début du mois de septembre un très
peu de temps après l'adoption ce décret
qui instaure donc l'état d'urgence de
particuliers dans cette zone puisque
c'est le président duda qui a adopté ce
décret ans le 2 septembre et dès le 3
septembre des journalistes polonais
était arrêté des collègues aussi trois
journaliste d'arte et ont été interpellé
le 28 septembre et aujourd'hui donc des
collègues confrères et consoeurs de
votre votre chaîne donc c'est une
situation
incompréhensible on ne voit pas ce qui
autorise les autorités polonaises à
instaurer
censure sur cette zone qu'ils méritent
en fait l'attention de la presse
qui mérite que les journalistes soient
présents ou rendre compte de ce qui se
passe réellement à l'arrière un acte de
censure une entrave clair à la liberté
d'informer quels sont les recours
possibles aujourd'hui
alors d'abord de le dénoncer vous savez
ça fait plus de traitements trois mois
maintenant que cette
censure d'état est imposé à la à la
presse dans cette zone je pense que il
faut que la presse réagissent aux
éclairs de notre côté la fédération
européenne des journalistes nous avons
introduit une dénonciation de ces faits
auprès du conseil de l'europe inquiète
la stance le 40 et libertés en europe 1
l'institution attaché à la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et nous
espérons donc d'une condamnation ferme y
compris de l'union européenne on ne
comprend pas comme union européenne
dénonce d'un côté ceux qui nous voient
comme une instrumentalisation de la
crise des réfugiés de la part de la
biélorussie mais en même temps tolère
camp de ses propres états membres la
pologne instauré ce type de censure au
sein même du gerry par aubin et en
violation complète et totale avec les
principes européens de liberté de la
presse je rappelle que le décret
présidentiel est interdit même la prise
d'image dans les zones frontalières donc
on ne peut même pas fumé quoi que ce
soit dans une vaste zone frontalière
avec la biélorussie
or on sait donc c'est que les autorités
polonaises
commettent des actes qui mérite d'être
montrées qui mérite d'être dénoncé un
rapport d'amnesty international a
démontré que des réfugiés afghans
avaient traversé la frontière s'étaient
retrouvés sur le territoire polonais et
ont été refoulés par les
gardes-frontières polonais ce qui est
contraire au revoir international émis à
des dons donc des actes illégaux commis
par les autorités polonaises on engage
la princesse de chine alors qu'elles
soient aujourd'hui les garanties
qu'offre le droit européen aux
journalistes pour exercer leur métier
notamment dans les zones jugées
dangereuses
mais malheureusement pas grand chose on
a évidemment les principes de liberté
qui sont de notre côté mais sur le
terrain quand un état comme comme la
pologne décide d'instaurer un état
d'urgence de sous prétexte de 10 raisons
sécuritaires et autres on est un peu
désarmée elle larmes que nous avons au
mas c'est celle qui est aussi du type de
notre ambition d'analystes s'est
informée et donc voila moi j'invite les
journalistes et confrères et les
consoeurs à continuer à faire leur
métier à se rendre sur place a dénoncé
cette censure publiquement
c'est une c'est la seule arme que nous
avons offert pression finalement je vais
donc vous cliquez sur les états qui ne
respectent pas leur engagement à
défendre et ricardo à ping merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
fédéral sur néral pardon de la
fédération européenne des journalistes